[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم فيدا باسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من الخرطوم التي تقع
فيها رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان وزيره خارجيه اسرائيل اليكوهن في
وقت تتزايد فيه مؤشرات التطبيع بين
الخرطوم وتل ابيب اما هذه الصور فتاتينا
من كييف التي تشهد حراكا دبلوماسيا مكثفا
عشيه القمه الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه في الشهر
الثاني عشر من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وهذه الصور تصلنا من البيت الابيض من
واشنطن حيث يقدم المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه ايجازه اليومي على وقع كثير من
التطورات والمواقف
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد الكشف عن زياره وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي الى الخرطوم الخارجيه
السودانيه تقول ان اتفاقا اقر بالمضيه
قدما في تطبيع العلاقات الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه تقول ان التوقيع النهائيه
يحتاج اشهرا وترهنه بتشكيل حكومه مدنيه
سودانيه وانتهاء الفتره الانتقاليه وقوى
شعبيه مناهضه للتطبيع تقول ان حكومه
الفتره الانتقاليه لا تملك حق توقيع اي
اتفاق مع اسرائيل
بعد حديث مصادر امريكيه عن عرض بلينكن خطه
لفرض السلطه الفلسطينيه سيطره امنيه على
جنين ونابلس في مقابله مع الجزيره مساعده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي فيكتوريا نولاند
تؤكد بحث الوفد الامريكي في رام الله
تعزيز البنى الامنيه في الضفه الغربيه
وبعد انتهاء جوله بلينكن حكومه نتنياهو
تصادر 32 مليون دولار من عائدات الضرائب
المستحقه للفلسطينيين
في حديث عن الرد على مواصله التسليح
الغربي لاوكرانيا الكريم يقول ان موسكو
ستستخدم كل قدراتها العسكريه للرد وبوتين
يتحدث عن عدوان غربي جديد وعلى وقع مزيد
من طلب الدعم لاوكرانيا قاده اوروبيون
يصلون الى كييف عشيه اول قمه من نوعها منذ
بدء الحرب
في جنوب شرق اسيا الولايات المتحده
والفلبين تبريمان اتفاقا يفتح ابواب اربع
قواعد عسكريه اضافيه امام الجنود
الامريكيين
تقول ان تعزيز واشنطن انتشار قواتها يزيد
التوتر وتتهمها بالتمسك بعقليه الحرب
البارده
وبعد مناورات مشتركه بين واشنطن
تقول ان التدريبات العسكريه في شبه جزيره
الكوريه تقود الى خط احمر خطير
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان مجلس السياده
السودانيه عقد رئيس عبد الفتاح البرهان
لقاء مع وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي ايلي
كوهين في الخرطوم والاتفاق على المضي قدما
في تطبيع العلاقات بينهما حيث قال وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي ان توقيع الاتفاق
النهائي سيكون في غضون اشهر بعد تشكيل
حكومه مدنيه في السودان وانتهاء الفتره
الانتقاليه والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
في رايكم من المستفيد في مسار التطبيع بين
السودان واسرائيل اما النتيجه فقد جاءت
على النحو التالي
51% قالوا ان المستفيد هو نتنياهو في ظل
ازمته الداخليه وقال 18% ان السودان
مستفيد في ظل الازمه السياسيه والاقتصاديه
التي يعيشها وذهب
31% الى ان الطبيعه يحقق مكسبا اقليميا
للاداره الامريكيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا مقابله خاصه مع
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
السياسيه فيكتوريا نولاند وحديث عن ملفات
عديده
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم بدا بحديث غير مكتمل عن زياره وفد
اسرائيلي الى الخرطوم سريعا تتلت الاخبار
الزائر هو وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
والمستقبل رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه
عبد الفتاح البرهان لقاء البرهان بكهين
ووفده بحسب اعلام المجلس بحث سبل ارساء
علاقات مع اسرائيل وتعزيز افاق التعاون
المشترك في مجالات عده لا سيما الامنيه
والعسكريه وبحسب اعلان مجلس السياده حث
الجانب السوداني الجانب الاسرائيلي على
العمل على تحقيق الاستقرار بين اسرائيل
والشعب الفلسطيني اما الخارجيه السودانيه
فاكدت ان اتفاقا تم مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
على المضي قدما في تطبيع العلاقات بين
البلدين
وبعد عودته من الزياره التي وصفها
بالتاريخيه قال ايلي كوهن انه قدم للبرهان
مسوده اتفاق سلاما بين تل ابيب والخرطوم
واشار الى ان هذا الاتفاق سيوقع العام
الجاري بعد تشكيل حكومه مدنيه في السودان
واضاف وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي في مؤتمر
صحفي ان الاتفاق مع السودان هو اتفاق سلام
مقابل سلامه مشيرا الى ان اسرائيل تعهدت
ضمن هذا الاتفاق بتقديم العون للسودان في
مجالات التنميه كافه وان للسودان مصلحه في
الاتفاق مع اسرائيل وذلك من خلال فتح
الابواب امام الولايات المتحده ودول غربيه
اخرى
هذا وقالت القوى الشعبيه لمقاومه التطبيع
بالسودان ان صفقه التطبيع مع اسرائيل مذله
وتنفصل عن قيم الشعب السوداني واضافت
القوى ان السودان لن يجني من الصفقه الا
السراب في الاثناء قالت رابطه اعلاميون من
اجل القدس ان حكومه الفتره الانتقاليه لا
تملك حق توقيع اي اتفاق مع اسرائيل وقال
المؤتمر الشعبي ان الغرض من محاوله
التطبيع اليائسه والمحمومه اي ظل السودان
تحت حكم العسكر بدعم من العدو الاسرائيلي
واضف المؤتمر ان محاولات التطبيع لا يكتب
لها النجاح مهما تكاثرت وبذلت لها وعود
الترغيب والترهيبه او بذلت لها هذه الوعود
من جانبه شدد التيار الاسلامي العريض على
رفض ما يجري الان من تعقيدات في المشهد
السياسي السوداني لانها صنعت خصيصا لتمرير
هذه الصفقات الفاسده حسب تعبيره
في هذا العرض نتابع ابرز محطات العلاقات
السودانيه الاسرائيليه ونعود بعد ذلك
لنقاش موسح
[موسيقى]
في الثالث من فبراير 2020 رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو يلتقي في
اوغندا رئيس المجلس السيادي في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان ومكتب نتنياهو يقول
انهما اتفقا على بدء الحوار من اجل تطبيع
العلاقات بين الطرفين في الخامس من الشهر
نفسه قال نتنياهو ان الخرطوم اعطت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه موافقه مبدئيه على
الطيران في الاجواء السودانيه في الثالث
والعشرين من اكتوبر 2020 وفي خضم الاعلان
عما سميت باتفاقيات ابراهم اعلن كل من
السودان واسرائيل انهم اتفقا بوساطه
امريكيه على تطبيع العلاقات بينهما وتزامن
ذلك مع تصريح لرئيس الامريكي انذاك دونالد
ترامب عزمه ازاله اسم السودان من قوائم
الارهاب في الخامس والعشرين من يناير 2021
وفي زياره هي الاولى من نوعها وزير
المخابرات الاسرائيلي انذاك
يصل الخرطوم على راسه وفن رسمي ويلتقي
وزير الدفاع السودانيه ياسين ابراهيم في
الثاني عشر من فبراير 2022
رئيسه مجلس السياده الانتقالي عبد الفتاح
البرهان يقول ان التعاون الامني
لاستخباراتي بين السودان واسرائيل لم
يتوقف منذ لقائهم مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو قبل عامين في
الاول من ابريل 2022 قالت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه ان وفد امنيا اسرائيليا عاليا
المستوى انها زياره رسميه الى السودان وان
مباحثاته هناك اقتصرت على الجوانب الامنيه
دون القضايا السياسيه في الثاني من فبراير
مجلس سياده السوداني يكشف عن لقاء جرى بين
رئيسه عبد الفتاح البرهان ووزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي كوهين في الخرطوم ويقول ان
اللقاء بين البرهان وكوهين تطرق الى تعزيز
العلاقات بين الطرفين وافاق التعاون
الاقتصادي والزراعي والعسكري
انضموا الينا من الخرطوم محمد الهادي عضو
المكتب التنفيذي لقوى الحريه والتغيير
مجموعه المجلس المركزي عبر الهاتف كما
ينضم الينا من الخرطومه اللواء امين
اسماعيل مجذوب استاذ اداره الازمات وفض
المنازعات لواء امين اسماعيل ما الدافع
وراء هذا اللقاء وما مغزى التوقيت
مساء الخير ومرحبا بكم ومرحبا بالسادة
المشاهدين
وضيفك الكريم حقيقه هذا اللقاء هو محاوله
من رئيس الوزراء الذي اعيد انتخابه
لمواصله ما تم الاتفاق عليه في عنتبه
وبالتالي فك طوق العزله الذي يعاني منه
حاليا
وايضا بالنسبه للخرطوم هنالك بتسويه غير
يعني عن اي عزله تتحدث الجانب الاسرائيلي
لديه علاقات مع الغرب مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هل هو في عزله
العزله التي يقصدها هي الصدامات مع الشعب
الفلسطيني حاليا
ووجود مقاومه من الشعب الاسرائيلي لعوده
الحكومه اليمنيه وبالتالي يحتاج الى تحقيق
انجاز بتوقيع السودان على ما يعرف
بالاتفاقيه الابراهيميه على الجانب
السوداني ايضا هنا الخرطوم ما الذي يحققه
نعم الجانب السوداني اصلا منذ عامين التقى
بجانب الاسرائيلي
وكان هنالك دعم بفتح التعاون مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وازاله السودان من
قائمه الدول الراعيه للارهاب الان هنالك
حاجه لاكمال التسويه التي ترعاها الرباعيه
وعلى راسها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبالتالي يمكن تمرير التسويه
ومعلوم انه من يوقع على الاتفاقيه
الابراهيميه يجب ان يبقى على الحكم
ولاحظنا هنالك اصرار على تكمله الاتفاقيه
بعد تشكيل الحكومه المدنيه فمن سيبقى ومن
سيشكل الحكومه ومن سيوقع هذه هي الفائده
التي يمكن ان تجنيها الاطراف الخرطوم ولكن
ساعود معك الى هذه الاسئله التي طرحت ولكن
اتحول الى ضيفي السيد محمد الهادي سيد
محمد اذا هنالك مكاسب للجانب السوداني من
هذه اللقاءات لماذا ترفضونها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والشكر لكم في
قناه الجزيره والتحيه من قبل ومن بعد
الشعب السوداني البطل وهو يعيش اصعب ايام
وبعد انقلاب 25 اكتوبر ونقول
[موسيقى]
الفريق البرهان متابعا
لعمليه
التطبيع مع الكيان الصهيوني في عمليه تكاد
تكون اصرار
الشعب السوداني الذي هو
مع قلبا وغالبا مع الشعب الفلسطيني في
قضيته العادله او استبقار ارضه من المغتصب
الصهيوني لذلك نقول
هذه العمليه هذا هذا التطبيق الذي يسعى
وراءه فريق البرهان
المكون العسكري لن يحقق للسودان سوى ان
يخرجوا من كيانوا العربي
ونضال ضد
محمد الهادي
السيد البرهان اوحى وكان هذا اللقاء يخدم
مصلحه الشعب
الفلسطيني بقوله ان الجانب السوداني حتى
الجانب الاسرائيلي على تحقيق الاستقرار مع
الجانب الفلسطيني
تماما نقول هذا لن يحقق هذا من لا يملك
لمن اعطانا لا يملك لمن لا يستحق هذا
القرار قرار التطبيع نحن عندنا في في في
في الحريه والتغيير اقرينا هذا امر يخص
الشعب السوداني ويقره الشعب السوداني
بمؤسساته المنتخبه هذا امر السلوك للمجلس
التشريعي غير بشانه الان حكومه الامر
الواقع هي التي تعزل الشعب السوداني وتعيش
في هذه المسائل الكبيره في منظمه العيش
والاقتصاد المنهار والامن المنهار لا طوق
نجاه طغنجاه لن يكون
بهذه
بالضغط على هذه القضيه العادله صديقي
الشعب
تتحدثون عن طوق نجاه لمن هم في السلطه
حاليا في السودان وهنا اعود للواء من
اسماعيل اللواء امين اذا محمد حمدان حماتي
يقول بانه لا علم لي بزياره الوفد
الاسرائيلي ولم
به هذا ما ظهر على شاشه الجزيره منذ قليل
كعاجل تنصل السيد احمد من هذا اللقاء ماذا
يعني
لواء امين اسماعيل هل تسمعني
طيب اعود الى السيد محمد الهادي سيد محمد
الهادي ذكرت بان هذا اللقاء انما هو خدمه
للمكون العسكري ولكن احد اضلع المكون
العسكري وهو السيد احمدتي يتنصل من هذا
اللقاء
نعم نحن الان في اطار عمليه سياسيه لتنقذ
البلاد من هذه الورطه الكبيره التي ادخلنا
فيها الانقلاب وبمثل هذه التصرفات من
الفريق البرهان يعيدنا الى المربع الاول
نقول كل الكلام بكل الامه الماليه هذه
التصرفات تعيدنا للمربع الاول انتم الان
وقعتم اتفاق اطار للخروجكم من السلطه
نهائيا وتسليم السلطه بحكومه مدنيه لتسيير
الفتره الانتقاليه الى
انتخابات حره مباشره هذا يعقب الامر ويعقد
المشهد السياسي في السودان اكثر مما هو
معقد
نصيحتنا للمقر العسكري النسب في العمليه
السياسيه ضعفه بهذا الشعب السوداني
اسمع من جديدنا اللواء امين اسماعيل لواء
امين التوقيع على اتفاق تطبيع مرهون
بالحكومه الجديده بالحكومه المدنيه ما هي
الضمانات ان توقع هذه الحكومه على اي
اتفاق تطبيع يعني شاهدنا الحكومه السابقه
ترفض اي نوع من انواع التطبيع وجاء ذلك
على لسان رئيسها في ذلك الوقت
نعم
الحكومه الاولى في الفتره الانتقاليه
شهدت زياره عن تبي
وصمطت قليلا ومررت مساله التطبيع الان
يبدو انهم يتحدثون عن موقف قوي في التسويه
والاتفاق الايطالي الضمانات الان لتوقيع
الاتفاقيه بعد تشكيل الحكومه وان يكون
المكون العسكري موجود في شراكه نوعا ما
على الساعه السياسيه بدون وجود المكونه
العسكري لن يتم التوقيع ولكن المكون
العسكري يقول بانه لن يكون في السلطه ما
ان يتم تشكيل حكومه مدنيه وبالتالي الا
يعني ذلك بان اليوم المكون العسكري يملي
شروطه على الحكومه التي من المفترض ان
تتكون في السودان
هذا هو الارباك الذي حدث اليوم ارباك كبير
بالترحيب بالزياره اولا ثم تنفيذ الزياره
والحديث عن
التطبيع والحديث عن التوقيع على الاتفاقيه
لابراهيميه وهذا يعني ان ان هنالك مناوره
كبيره من اطراف عديده الان هنالك مناوره
اكبر في القاهره باجتماع الكتله
الديمقراطيه والان المكونه العسكري يسحب
المصاب باعتبار ان مساله التطبيع ترعاها
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه واوروبا ودول
الترويكا وربما يحدث ضغط على الطرف الاخر
وهو المجلس المركزي للموافقه على وجود
نوعي للمكون العسكري حتى يتم ضمان التوقيع
على الاتفاقيه فهذا هو الايرباك وهذه هي
الساحه السياسيه ستشهد في الساعات القادمه
جبهه الرافضه وجبهه مرنه وجبهه مؤيده
شكرا لك اللواء امين اسماعيل مجذوب واستاذ
اداره الازمات وفضل المنازعات كنت معنا من
الخرطوم والشكر موصول للسيد محمد الهادي
عضو المكتب التنفيذي والمتحدث باسم قوى
الحريه والتغيير مجموعه المجلس المركزي
[موسيقى]
في مقابله مع الجزيره اجريناها قبل الحصاد
قالت مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
للشؤون السياسيه فيكتوريا نولاند ان الوضع
في اسرائيل والاراضي الفلسطينيه مقلق
واردنا على سؤال حول مناقشه خطه امنيه
امريكيه مع الفلسطينيين قالت نولاند ان
الامريكيين بحثوا مع الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين تعزيز البنى الامنيه في
الضفه الغربيه
عندما كان الوزير في رام الله بقي مساعده
في اسرائيل للتواصل معك الى الجانبين
وخاصه في الضفه الغربيه لتعزيز الامن وضمن
ان الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين يحمون الناس
وان المؤسسات الامنيه قائمه وتؤدي مهامها
وان هناك قنوات اتصال مفتوحه وسنرى ما
تؤول اليه الامور ولدينا امل ان التوتر
سينخفض
كان موقع اكسيوس نقل امس عن مسؤولين
امريكيين واسرائيليين قولهم ان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن ضغط على
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس لقبول وتنفيذ
خطه امنيه امريكيه خلال زيارته الخطه تهدف
الى وفق اكسيوس الى اعاده سيطره السلطه
الفلسطينيه على مدينتي جنين ونابلس وتشمل
تدريب قوه فلسطينيه خاصه سيتم نشرها في
هذه المنطقه لمواجهه من سمتهم الميليشياتا
وذكر الموقع ان الاسرائيليين ايدوا الخطه
الامريكيه بينما تحفظ المسؤولون
الفلسطينيون عليها لكون الخطه لا تتضمن اي
مطالب من اسرائيل كتقليل توغلات الجيش
الاسرائيلي في المدن الفلسطينيه كما ابلغ
الجانب الامريكي بانهم لا يملكون الشرعيه
للعمل خلال النهار عندما يشن الجيش
الاسرائيلي غارات في الليل
يؤدي الى مقتل فلسطينيين
ينضم الينا من رام الله غسان الخطيب
واستاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت
دكتور خطيب اذا يتكرر الحديث عن البنيه
الامنيه نولاند ذكرت في مقابله اجريناها
قبل الحصاد بانه تم النقاش حول تعزيز
البنى الامنيه في الضفه الغربيه كيف
تفهمون هذا التعبير
نحن نفهم هذا التعبير بانه محاوله
اسرائيليه امريكيه لوضع التازم الحالي في
سياق امني في حين في حقيقه الامر
التوتر الحالي والتدهور الحالي وتفاقم
الصراع الحالي ياتي في سياق سياسي ناتج عن
استمرار الاحتلال وغياب اي عمليه سياسيه
وافتقار العلاقه بين الطرفين الى احترام
القانون الدولي والشرعيه الدوليه
والاتفاقات الموقعه وبالتالي اي معالجه
امنيه مكتوب عليها الفشل لان الواقع
الامني الصعب هو ناتج عن الواقع الاحتلالي
السياسي
واستمرار اسرائيل في محاوله حسم الصراع عن
طريق توسيع المستوطنات وعن طريق التضييق
على المواطنين الفلسطينيين الامر الذي ولد
فعل مقاومه باشكال مختلفه من الشعب
الفلسطيني التي لن تتوقف الا في اطار
سياسي يعيد الامل للشعب الفلسطيني
بامكانيه انهاء الاحتلال تمهيدا لنيلهم
لحقهم في تقرير المصير سيد غسان ولكن ماذا
عن السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مساعده وزير
الخارجيه تقول بانه تم مناقشه هذه البنى
الامنيه مع الجانبين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطينيه ايضا كيف يستقيم هذا الحديث
مع كلام السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه بانها
اوقفت التنسيق الامني مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي
يستقيم لان السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
ايضا اعلنت بانها في هذه اللقاءات مع
الجانب الامريكي
قدمت مجموعه من المتطلبات الضروريه من اجل
خفض حده التوتر ومعظم هذه المتطلبات هي
ذات طابع سياسي
وليس امني وبالتالي يعني الجانب الفلسطيني
بمختلف مكوناته رغم الخلافات الداخليه
ورغم الوضع الداخلي الصعب الا ان جميع
مكونات الشعب الفلسطيني
متفقه على ان المشكله والازمه سياسيه وان
هذا الصراع ياتي في اطار وسياق الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي غير القانوني وغير الشرعي
والمقاومه الطبيعيه لهذا الاحتلال
وبالتالي معالجه اي نتاج عن ذلك مثل
النتائج الامنيه يجب ان يكون في سياق
سياسي هذا امر لا يختلف الفلسطينيون بكل
مكوناتهم طيب الاجراءات الاسرائيليه لم
تتوقف عند هذا الحد وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي زعيم حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
بتلاقي
اعلن عن مصادره نحو 32 مليون دولار من
عائدات الضرائب المستحقه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه وقال انه وقع على خصم ضعف
المبلغ الذي كانت اسرائيل تخصمه من اموال
عائدات الضرائب للسلطه الفلسطينيه بما
يوازي قيمه الاموال التي تحولها السلطه
الفلسطينيه لعائلات الاسرى والشهداء وفق
تعبيره جاء ذلك بعد يومين من زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للاراضي الفلسطينيه
وتاكيدها على ضروره وقف التصعيد ومعارضه
بلاده للاجراءات الاحاديه مره جديده اليك
سيد غسان بعد يومين من زياره بلينكن بعد
حديثه عن ضروره خفض التصعيد ووقف التوتر
الا ان الجانب الاسرائيلي يواصل من
اجراءاته العقابيه يعني الى اي مدى نجحت
هذه الزياره في تخفيف التوتر حسب ما اعلن
لم تنجح هذه الزياره ولن تنجح الجهود
الامريكيه في
معالجه الاوضاع المتفاقمه لان هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه محكومه ومضطره
باستمرار سياسه القمع وسياسه التشدد
وسياسه الضغط اكثر واكثر على الفلسطينيين
لارضاء قاعدتها الانتخابيه لان هذه
الحكومه جاءت على ارضيه انتخابات شعبويه
وهي مضطره للاستمرار في ارضاء هذه القاعده
الانتخابيه عن طريق مزيد من الاجراءات
القمعيه مثل التي تفضلت بها وغيرها مما
يحدث يوميا في الاراضي المحتله وهذا بدء
الدوري الامريكي سيد غسان
الدوري الامريكي لم يكن جادا في هذه
الزياره الجانب الامريكي لم يستثمر اي ثقل
سياسي للضغط على اسرائيل لوضع حد لسياستها
المتطرفه الجانب الامريكي محرج بعض الشيء
بسبب تشكيله هذه الحكومه وسياستها ولكن
ربما الظروف السياسيه الداخليه في
الولايات المتحده واعتبارات كثيره تجعلها
غير قادره او غير راغبه او غير مستعده
لتناول جذور الازمه وهي الجذور السياسيه
وهي استمرار الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وطالما
بقيت سياسه الامريكيه على السطح وتعالج
الامور من المنظور الاسرائيلي اي الامني
فمكتوب عليها بالفشل الذريع كما نلاحظ
الان شكرا لك غسان الخطيب استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت كنت معنا من رام
الله
الاجراءات والاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
لاقت ادانه حقوقيه صدرت عن منظمته
ان اغلاق اسرائيل منازل عائلات فلسطينيه
يشتبه في قيام احد ابنائها بهجمات ضد
اسرائيل يرقى الى مستوى العقاب الجماعي
ووصفته بجريمات حرب واضاف القائمون على
المنظمه انه لا يمكن تبرير معاقبه اسرائيل
للعائلات الفلسطينيه بهدم منازلها
واطاردها الى الشارع
طبعا نذكر ان المقابله كامله مع مساعده مع
مساعده وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون
السياسيه فيكتوريا نولاند ستكون بعد قليل
في الحصاد
[موسيقى]
قال الكريم ان موسكو ستستخدم كل قدراتها
للرد على تسليح الغرب لاوكرانيا كلام
الحقه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بوعيد
بالرد على ما وصفه بالعدوان الغربي الجديد
على بلاده من خلال اوكرانيا وخلال مشاركته
في فعاليات الذكرى الثمانين لانتصار في
معركه
استحضر بوتين مواجهه بلاده مع المانيا
قائلا ان نازيه ظهرت مجددا وتهدد روسيا
بالدبابات الالمانيه
الان للاسف نرى ان اديولوجيه النازيه في
شكلها الحديث تشكل مره اخرى تهديدا مباشرا
لامن بلدنا نحن مضطرون مجددا لصد عدوان
الغرب الجماعي يتم تهديدنا مره اخرى
بدبابات الالمانيه المرصعه بالصلبان ومره
اخرى سيقاتلون روسيا على ارض اوكرانيا
بايدي النازيين الجدد من اتباع بانديرا
لكن اولئك الذين يجرون الدول الغربيه بما
في ذلك المانيا الى حرب جديده مع روسيا
ومن يتوقعون الفوز على روسيا في ساحه
المعركه لا يفهمون على ما يبدو ان الحرب
مع روسيا ستكون مختلفه تماما قادرون على
الرد عليهم ولن يقتصر الامر على المدرعات
هذا الحديث الروسي ياتي على وقع طلب
اوكراني مستمر لمزيد من الدعم عشيه قمه
اوروبيه اوكرانيه مرتقبه في كيافا على
الارض قال وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
تقديرات تشير الى ان القوات الروسيه
استدعت قرابه نصف مليون جندي لا 300 الف
كما اعلنت موسكو رسميا بينما كشف مجلس
الامن القومي الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
تستعد لشن هجوم واسع خلال الاسابيع
القليله القادمه من جهه اخرى قالت وزاره
الدفاع البيلاروسيه انها تملك صواريخ
اسكندر القادره على تنفيذ اي مهمه عسكريه
بعيون على الحدود يستقبل الرئيس الاوكراني
مسؤولين اوروبيين في العاصمه على راس
القادمين الى هنا رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ومسؤول سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي يركز الرئيس الاوكراني
في حديثه مع الاوروبيين على التخوفات من
حشود عسكريه روسيه على الحدود الشرقيه
الشماليه وفي المناطق الجنوبيه وفق مجلس
الامن القومي الاوكراني فان القوات
الروسيه تستعد لشن هجوم واسع خلال
الاسابيع القليله القادمه سيعيد الروس
مشهد بدايه الحرب ويبداون هجوما من الشرق
والشمالي والجنوب حينها وصلت القوات
الروسيه الى مشارف العاصمه بدات زحفا
يستهدف كييف من الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه
وسيطرت على مساحات واسعه في الجنوب والشرق
اليوم يقول وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه استدعت قرابه نصف مليون
جندي من الاحتياط وليس 300 الف كما اعلن
سابقا بشكل رسمي
ان القلق الاوكراني له ما يدعمه في الشمال
تقول وزاره الدفاع البيلاروسيه انها باتت
تملك صواريخ اسكندر القادره على تنفيذ اي
مهمه عسكريه هذا بالاضافه الى منظومات
صاروخيه تضرب الى مدى يصل الى 300 كيلومتر
مئات الكيلومترات هذه تعني تغطيه نصف
الاراضي الاوكرانيه تقريبا بصواريخ من
بيلاروسيا هذه التصريحات تاتي بعد اختتام
مناورات روسيه بلا روسيه انتهت قبل ايام
قليله قرب الحدود بين بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا
وفق المخابرات الاوكرانيه فقد شهد البحر
الاسود كذلك تغييرات في نشاط القوات
الروسيه يزيد النشاط الروسي وتتحرك حاملات
الصواريخ على بعد 500 كيلومتر عن العاصمه
كييف وبالتالي تغطيه كل المناطق
الاوكرانيه تقريبا بالصواريخ الروسيه
هذه التخوفات والحشود تعكس الوضع
الميدانيه المتعثره للطرفين
لا يستطيع اي من الجيشين حسب تقدمه على
الجبهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه وتحديدا
ويعجزون عن التقدم اكثر للسيطره على ما
تبقى من اقليم دونيتسك ويتوقف الاوكرانيون
كذلك ويعجزون عن استعاده السيطره على مزيد
من المساحات في الاقليم او التقدم اكثر
نحو هكذا يترقب الطرفان خطط كل منهما
وتحضيراته الى الاسابيع القادمه تنتظر هي
الهجوم الروسيا واسعا وتنتظر موسكو ما قد
يقدمه الغرب من دعم الليكييف يقلب
المعادله
ينضم الينا من موسكو الكسندر التامونوف
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من برلين
دانيال بومر رئيس تحرير صحيفه ديفليت
الالمانيه سيده الكسون ابدا معك بما قاله
الكريم
كل قدراتها للرد على تسليح الغرب
لاوكرانيا كيف سيترجم هذا الكلام على
الارض وفي ميدان المعركه
في موسكو هناك الكثير من الاسباب
والتبريرات التي لم تستخدم حتى الان لدى
روسيا ما يزيد عن الف صاروخ اسكندر ذو
المدى 1500 كيلو متر هذا ليس سر هذه
الصواريخ
البالستيه لم تستخدم ولا مره حتى الان ضد
الجسور او المباني او السكك الحديديه
ولدها روسيا ايضا
القنابل
المتفجره ذاتيا التي لها فعل الاسلحه
التكتيكيه
وهي
من الاسلحه التي تعتبر مدمره ولكنها لا
تعتبر من اقوى عفوا الاسلحه المراه الشامل
لدى روسيا ايضا الكثير من
الادوات التي ممكن ان تستخدم لدينا خمسه
عشر الف دبابه ممكن ان يمد الغرب اوكرانيا
بمئات الدبابات ولكنها ستحترق كما احترقت
في سوريا سيد دانيال الجانب الروسي يقول
ان مد اوكرانيا باسلحه متطوره وصواريخ
بعيده المدى انما سيؤدي الى توسيع رقعه
الحرب لكي تحمل روسيا اراضيها بالتالي كيف
تخدم هذه الاسلحه اوكرانيا
انها ستكون ذات فائده كبيره وتخدمهم خدمه
كبيره وتقدم لاوكرانيا فرصه قيام بهجمات
مرتده
الناجحه ولتحرير الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن
المشكله هي ان هذه الاسلحه تاتي في وقت
متاخر جدا والسبب الرئيسي لذلك هو التردد
خاصه من قبل الالمانيا تردد في توفير هذه
الاسلحه الثقيله خاصه الدبابات الالمانيه
الطلب قدم في نهايه الصيف لسنه الماضيه
حتى بدايه الخريف وتطلب الامر بالنسبه
لالمانيا حتى بدايه هذه السنه لتقرر اخيرا
على
تسليم هذه الدبابات والنتائج ستكون اننا
سنشهد
اشهر اخرى طويله من القتال حيث روسيا
برمي مئات الالاف من قواتها على ارض
المعركه لان روسيا نفسها
متاثره جدا وقد خسرت الكثير من معداتها في
الاشهر الماضيه وبالتالي الامر سيتطلب
شهور ان من الزمن بالنسبه لاوكرانيا لكي
يشغلوا ويستخدموا هذه الاسلحه التي يقدمها
الغرب لهم على الاقل ثلاثه اشهر بعض من
الان بعد ان تستطيع استخدام هذه الدبابات
يقدمها الغرب بشكل جيد ايضا الامر يتعلق
باطاله امت هذه الحرب وانا لا اتفق مع ما
القول بان تسليم الاجهزه المعدات او
الاسلحه هذه تطيل لمده الحرب واكلنا ان
هذه الاسئله جديده قد تقصر مده الحرب
لانها ستؤدي الى نصر باوكراني اسرع ولكن
الغرب مع الاسف
ضيعوا وقتا ثمينا كثيرا لفتره طويله وهذا
سيكلف حياه البشر سيد اليكساندر على الرغم
من الاسلحه التي ذكرتها وعددتها الا ان لم
تستطع حسم الحرب ونحن على مشارف انتهاء
العام الاول من بدايتها
روسيا حتى الان لم تقم بقصف المدن
الاوكرانيه ولم تقصف السكك الحديديه ولم
تقصف الجسور قد تكونوا تتناسا هذا ان
روسيا تفهم جيدا ان جميع هذه المناطق التي
تحررها سوف تصبح روسي روسيه حتى الان
انضم لنا حوالي ثمان ملايين مواطن عدا
القرم وهم غاليين علينا جدا لذلك نحن لا
نتاجر بارواح
تماما كما ان الرئيس السوري لم يكن يريد
ان يقتل
المدن وصلت الى العاصمه كييف وقصفت البنيه
التحتيه الكهرباء والمياه كيف لم تقصف
المدن
[موسيقى]
هذا ليس حقيقيا هذا ليس حقيقيا روسيا كانت
تقصف المنشات التابعه للطاقه كم من
المواطنين الذين قتلوا في اوكرانيا من
القصف الروسي هل ممكن ان تذكري لي الرقم
انا ممكن ان اقول لك ان هناك
1500 شخص قتلوا من القصف
الاوكراني في الدنباص ان
اوكرانيا تستخدم اسلحه محظوره ولدينا
شظايا هذه الصواريخ ولا يجوز ان تتحدثي
بدون اي براهين وهذا شيء غير صحيح انا
انقل لك الصوره حسب ما يقول الجانب
الاوكراني انتم تنفول ذلك وبالطبع لم
تعطينا اي براهين على استخدام اسلحه محضره
دوليا استخدمتها اوكرانيا على كل الاحوال
اريد ان اسمع من السيد
دانيال بومر سيد دانيال هنالك قمه اوروبيه
اوكرانيه ما هو المتوقع من هذه القمه
اكثر شيء هو هذا بارض
للتضامن مع اوكرانيا فجزء كبير من قاده
الاتحاد الاوروبي وصلوا الى اوكرانيا
انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد
تعممون عضويه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ورغم من
الكثيرين يعتقدون انه ليس من الواقع ان
تنضم الى الاتحاد الاوروبي في المستقبل
القريب لكنها اتحاد هذا يود ان يبين بانهم
ينظرون الى هذا الطلب بنظره جديه وانهم
سيناقشون ذلك الامر مع اوكرانيا حول
الخطوات اللازمه التي ينبغي ان اتخذوها من
اجل الحصول على عضويه الاتحاد الاوكرانيون
انفسهم يقولون ان اعضاء كامل عضويه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي خلال سنتين لكن معظم
المراقبين يكون هذا غير واقعي رئيس فرنسي
ماكرون قال
طلب عقود من الزمن اللي استطاع اوكرانيا
انضمام الذي هو امر اكثر واقعيا ولكن
الكثير
يعتقدون ان اوكرانيا ايضا
تعامل كانه عضو في اتحاد الاوروبي
الاعتبار ان في هذه السنه فقط ثمانيه اشهر
مليار اليورو لاوكرانيا عدى الدعم العسكري
ومتى هذا مجرد الجانب المالي وايضا
اوكرانيا سمح لها بتصدير بضائعها الاتحاد
الاوروبي دون اي
تعريفه او ضرائب كانها عضو وهذا سيكون حد
مواضيع المناقشه في القمه وامكانيه تمديد
هذا الامتياز لهم شكرا
رئيس تحرير صحيفه ديفليت الالمانيه كنت
معنا من برلين ونشكر من موسكو الكسندر
ارثا مونوف الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
الى جنوب شرق اسيا حيث فتحت الفلبين ابواب
اربع قواعد عسكريه اضافيه امام القوات
الامريكيه القرار ياتي بعد ابرام اتفاق
بين واشنطن ومانيلا في تطوير للشراكه
العسكريه بين البلدين هذا الامر ازعج
الصين مجددا التي اتهمت الولايات المتحده
بالتمسك بعقليه الحرب البارده مشيره الى
تعزيز الانتشار العسكري الامريكي في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ يرفع مستوى التوتر
ويزعزع السلامه في الاقليم ذاته تحتاج على
تعاون عسكري امريكي اخر معسول في اشاره
الى تدريبات عسكريه جديده في شبه جزيره
الكوريه حيث قالت بيونج ان هذه التدريبات
تقود الى خط احمر خطير
تعزيز الانتشار حول الصين وكوريا الشماليه
هدف يبدو في خلفيه زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لكل من كوريا الجنوبيه والفلبين
وما صاحبها من تدريبات واتفاقات زياره
اوستن للمنطقه هي السادسه خلال عامين
وقرات في كل من بيجين وبيونج يانج كمحفز
لمزيد من التوتر الاقليمي والعوده لاجواء
الحرب البارده
تتمسك الولايات المتحده بعقليه الحرب
البارده ذات المحصله الصفريه وتعزز
انتشارها العسكري في المنطقه وقد ادى ذلك
الى زياده التوتر وتقويض السلام
والاستقرار بدورها علقت كوريا الشماليه
على المناورات الامريكيه مع الشطر الجنوبي
معتبره اياها سياسات عدائيه امريكيه وقال
بيان للخارجيه في بيونغيانج ان وعود اوستن
بنشر ما وصفها باصول استراتيجيه امريكيه
تفضي لتحويل شبه جزيره الكوريه لترسانه
حربيه ضخمه ومنطقه حرب عاليه الخطوره في
العاصمه الفلبينيه عززت الولايات المتحده
وجودها العسكري باتفاق يرفع عدد القواعد
الفلبينيه المتاح استخدامها للقوات
الامريكيه من خمس الى تسعه بعضها قريب من
مياه متنازع عليها
يسرنا ان نعلن ان الرئيس ماركوس قد وافق
على منحنا اربعه مواقع اضافيه في اطار
اتفاقيه التعاون الدفاعي المعزز ليصل
العدد الاجمالي للمواقع الى تسعه انا ممتن
للرئيس ماركوس لهذا القرار تحدث وزير
الدفاع الامريكي عن التصدي لما وصفها
بالانشطه المزعزعه للاستقرار في المياه
المحيطه بالفلبين بما في ذلك بحر الفلبين
الغربي واستمرار الصين في مزاعمها غير
المشروعه هناك وفق قوله تتحسب الصين كثيرا
لما ترى انه قوس متنام حولها من القواعد
الامريكيه في شرق اسيا في اليابان مثلا
وجود عسكري امريكي منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه هو الاكبر خارج الاراضي الامريكيه
بما يجاوز 50 الف جندي كما تعد كوريا
الجنوبيه الثالثه اكبر مستضيف للوجود
العسكري الامريكي بعد اليابان والمانيا
وبها قاعده هانفرز الكبرى عالميا مساحه
وعدد قوات
التوطيد الاحدث للنفوذ الامريكي المتاخم
للصين تمثل في الاتفاق الاخير مع الفلبين
والتي لا تبعد عن تايوان
متر في المنطقه ايضا اندونيسيا بجزرها
الكثيره وتسعى الولايات المتحده
لاستمالتها رغم النفوذ الاقتصادي الصيني
الضخم بها
والان نعود الى المقابله الخاصه التي
اجريناها قبل الحصاد مع فيكتوريا نولد
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
السياسيه وقد سالتها اولا في ملف حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا عن حزمه عقوبات جديده
تستعد واشنطن لفرضها على موسكو والموعد
المتوقع لاقرار هذه الحزمه
هذه الفرصه هي المشاركه معكم هذا اليوم
انت محقه بما اننا نقترب من فصل الربيع
نتوقع ان الاوكرانيين يودون اطلاقه هجوم
جديد الخريطه الحاليه للاحتلال الروسي
لاوكرانيا خطره جدا لهم لذا الولايات
المتحده تعمل مع حلفائها واصدقائها لتوفير
ما يحتاجون اليه لضمان استمرارهم في طرد
روسيا من اراضيهم هذه الحرب كما تعلمون
يمكن ان تنتهي غدا اذا ما اخترت روسيا
الانسحاب من اوكرانيا واذا اوقفت القتال
فالحرب ستنتهي اما اذا اوقفت اوكرانيا
القتال فستنتهي اوكرانيا
هم يطالبون بصواريخ بعيده المدى وبمقاتلات
هل يمكن ان تنظر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى هذه المطالب
نعمل معهم عن كثب وبكل كثافه بشان ماهيه
احتياجاتهم اذا كانت احتياجاتهم تتضمن
اجهزه دفاع جويه لحمايه اجوائهم واذا ما
ارادوا ايضا مدافعوا صواريخ بعيده المدى
لان الرؤوس سحب قواتهم الى الوراء ويطلقون
صواريخ من مدن ابعد لهذا السبب نحن نعمل
مع حلفائنا لتلبيه احتياجات اوكرانيا وترد
روسيا من اراضيها
الى هذه الحزمه كيف تختلف هذه الحزمه عن
سابقاتها من حيث من حيث طبيعه والنوعيه
الاسلحه المقدمه للجانب الاوكراني
اعتقد انه في كل مرحله التكتيكات الروسيه
اصبحت اكثر وحشيه ليس فقط في ميادين
القتال ولكن رايتهم كيف يهاجمون البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه كمنشات الماء والكهرباء
يحاولون تجميد الشعب الاوكراني في فصل
الشتاء سيحتاج الاوكرانيون للدفاع عن
انفسهم ليس فقط الى معدات في الميدان
المعركه وانما ايضا في محيط البنيه
التحتيه الحرجه ايضا في كل مرحله يبني
الروس التكتيكاتهم الخاصه بهم اليوم
يلجاون الى الايرانيين والكوريين
الشماليين وحماس للحصول على السلاح وياتون
ايضا بمزيد من الذخيره العنقوديه
والبدفاعيه بعيده المدى لذا الاوكرانيون
يحتاجون الى زياده قدراتهم اكثر حتى لا
يخسر المعركه
اكثر من مره اشرتي بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تناقش مع الحلفاء نوعيه الاسلحه
والمعدات التي يتم تقديمها لاوكرانيا
بولندا عبرت عن استعدادها لتزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات اف 16 كيف تنظر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لذلك
واخوي
قلنا لحلفائنا انهم اذا كانوا معنيين
بتزويد اوكرانيا بالطائرات فهذا خيارهم
طائره اف 16 موجوده في دول الجوار وهي
الطائرات معقده وتحتاج الى الكثير من
التدريب لكن المهم ان يسيطر الاوكرانيون
على اجوائهم الروس خاسر الكثير من
الطائرات والمروحيات ربما اكثر من نصف
دفاعاتهم الجويه اذا هذه هي حرب وحشيه
واوكرانيا بحاجه الى الدفاع عن نفسها
بعدا عن احاديث الاسلحه ونوعيه الاسلحه
لنتحدث في الاطار الدبلوماسي وزير
الخارجيه
الروسيه يقول ان الجميع يريد انهاء الصراع
مع اوكرانيا لكن لا احد يرغب في اقناع
اكياف بالمسار الدبلوماسي كيف تردون على
ذلك
الامم المتحده لا ارى اي خطه السلام تاتي
من روسيا هم فقط يرمون بالمقاتلين في
بخموت ويزيدون من حده هجماتهم هذه مقوله
شريره من قبل الروس كما قلت هذه الحرب
يمكن ان تنتهي غدا اذا ما توقفت روسيا عن
القتال غدا ولكن اذا ما توقفت اوكرانيا
على القتال فستنتهي اوكرانيا غدا
لكن الجانب الروسي يقول بان الغرب لا يشجع
اوكرانيا على ان تكون واقعيه في طاعاتها
مع الوضع القائم او المستجد على الارض وهي
ضم اقاليم بالفعل لروسيا من اوكرانيا
كما رايت من التصريحات الروسيه هم يطالبون
ليس فقط من اوكرانيا وانما من العالم اجمع
بالاعتراف بضمهم غير الشرعي وان يعترف
بهذه الاراضي كاراضي روسيه وهي اراد
احتلها خلال المعركه واذا ما فتحنا هذا
الباب فسنفتحه امام كل ديكتاتور وطاغيه
وكل جار كبير ليطلع جيرانه الاصغر طبعا لا
نقبل بذلك وانا متاكده انكم انتم ايضا لن
تقبلوا بذلك وما نقوم به نحن الولايات
المتحده وحلفاؤنا وبلدان مثل قطر التي
وقفت مع اوكرانيا ضد ضم اراضيها هو اننا
نقول للروس لن نقبل بما تقومون به لا يمكن
ان تقرروا ان نصف جيرانكم هي جزء من ارضكم
هذا لن يقبل به احد
الكثير من الملفات تحملينها في جعبتك في
جولتك الى المنطقه ما ابرز هذه الملفات
وما الهدف من زياره الدوحه
في الحوار الاستراتيجي بين الولايات
المتحده وقطر والذي بداه وزير الخارجيه
انطوني بينكن مع وزير الخارجيه القطري
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني كانت
لدينا فرصه للحديث عن قضايا عده تحدثنا عن
روسيا واوكرانيا وعن اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
وعن ايران وفانستان وافريقيا ايضا بين
الولايات المتحده وقطر حوار فعال ومكثف
وجهود مشتركه بشان كل القضايا التي يتهمون
على هذا الكوكب وهي شراكه مهمه وعظيمه
اشرت الى السيده بلنكن وهو كان بالمنطقه
بالفعل منذ ايام ما الذي حققه على مستوى
الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
كما تعلمون فان الوضع مقلق للغايه فقد
راينا عنفا في اسرائيل وراينا عنفا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه ايضا التركيز الاساسي
لرحله الوزير بلينكن كان بدء حوار مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده ولكن بسبب
تغير الظروف اصبحت الرحله تتعلق بكيفيه
مساعده الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين لخفض
التوتر والعوده الى الحوار ولكسر دوامه
العنف السيء هذه والعوده الى مسارح
للدولتين
هل كانت هنالك خطه امنيه امريكيه تمت
مناقشتها مع الجانب الفلسطيني
وداد
عندما كان الوزير في رام الله بقي مساعده
في اسرائيل للتواصل مع كلا الجانبين وخاصه
في الضفه الغربيه لتعزيز الامن وضمان ان
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين يحمل الناس وان
المؤسسات الامنيه قائمه وتؤدي مهامها وان
هناك قنوات اتصال مفتوحه وسنرى ما ستؤول
اليه الامور لدينا امل ان التوتر سينخفض
لدينا دقيقه واحده فقط اريد ان اسال عن
الملف النووي الايراني المفاوضات متوقفه
منذ فتره ما هي النقطه التي توقفت عندها
هذه المفاوضات ما هي المشكله في هذه
المفاوضات
كان هناك على الطاوله اتفاق شبه كاملا
لعده اشهر لكن ايران اختارت عدم التوقيع
عليه للاسف ايران اصبحت اكثر عدوانيه الان
في انحاء العالم واكثر عدوانيه مع شعبها
في الداخل لدينا مشكلات تتفاقم مع ايران
بما في ذلك الدعم الذي يقدمونه لروسيا
كالمسيرات وتكنولوجيا الصواريخ قصيره
المدى وهناك بواعث قلق حقيقيه الافكار
موجوده بالنسبه الى الملف النووي والحل
موجود ولكن للاسف لم يوافق لريانون عليها
شكرا لك يا سيده فيكتوريا نولاند مساعده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون السياسيه
بهذه المقابله ننهي الحصاد لهذه الليله
تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]